ladies and gentlemen we just saw a
wrinkle in time if you've read the book
it is 100% accurate I would know I
definitely didn't read the book and I
would know I read it a long time ago and
don't have a tremendous recollection of
the events in the book but let's put the
book to the side and judges movie on its
own merits today people here's our list
of reasons to see and reasons not to see
and we'll see which one outweighs what
reason to see number one would have to
be at the cast ladies and gentlemen I'm
not gonna try to pretend like I actually
remember every actor's name here so just
want to start off by saying two kids
storm read meg is great in it Levi
Miller Calvin who you know you might
have seen him as that creepy kid in that
one movie that he did last year
that's like home alone butter you know
r-rated better watch out and the last
one kid Derek McCabe who plays Charles
Wallace in the film storm read as the
lead in this film she had some of the
most emotional moments in this movie and
really got me to a point of Tears man
and then you have you know your Oprah
your Mindy Kaling your Reese Witherspoon
your Chris Pine like all the adult
characters who aren't as like sensual
but you know they help everything along
I thought the little kid who plays
Charles Wallace he's adorable in the
movie and I can't give it away but I
notice amongst the crowd we went through
one of those press screenings I know so
much the crowd that when they were
raving about the performances it was
really Charles Wallace character that
people started really raving about
unfortunately it would totally ruin the
movie for you guys if we told you why
it's the performance that really stood
out for a lot of people for me it would
have to be the main performance of storm
read as a lead character in here that
really stood out to me and she was
someone who had the most emotional depth
here and she had scenes that brought
both John and I to tears in the middle
of this movie man Chris Pine he does a
really good job in it there's an
argument to be made about wasn't
necessary to cast famous people for
likeness which miss whatsit and miss who
there's an argument to be made for that
but I think Chris Pine was one of those
celebrity actors cast in it that really
did bring elevation to his performance
as well but Oprah does what you might
expect Oprah to do when you see here in
this movie Reese Witherspoon
a good job Mindy Kaling was the one that
John and I were a little bit different
in Yin of because she did a good job
yeah she does a good job but I don't
think he'd really needed to cast Mindy
Kaling for that role I think he could
have been an unknown actress and it
would have been fine hey I feel like I
might have gotten distracting I feel
like that might have felt Lobb sided
like you've got two celebrities to play
these two roles and somebody else for
this one you know like they are a trio
they need to be complete I guess I think
that if it was an unknown that role
might have stood out a little bit more
bone you have Mindy Kaling as his
character who's primarily just reading
inspirational quotes she doesn't really
do anything that would bring a Mindy
Kaling performance to life I feel like
if it was an unknown might have stood
out a little bit more I feel like you
could argue the same thing about Oprah
then because Oprah just brings her Oprah
gravitas but that character isn't
written in such a way where nobody else
could have done it yeah but she actually
has lines that are written that are not
just quotes from other famous people yes
I don't know I don't feel like that
takes away from that character in any
way I just I do are we hung up on the
reason to see number two the visual
effects there are a whole lot of visual
effects in this movie it is a
extravaganza of sorts and that's
probably one of the strongest elements
throughout as far as I'm concerned
anyway there's a whole lot of zgi in
this movie in it for the most part looks
terrific
it's really well lit and it's really
imaginative to the designs are all very
gorgeous very vibrant very colorful some
of the stuff that works the best out of
this whole movie is just how they bring
these different realms and places and
these strange sci-fi occurrences to life
because there is definitely a fantasy
element but also a strong sci-fi element
to this movie and I thought the effects
really brought those to life in a really
nice way we were no reason to sing
number three reason to see number three
the last half without spoiling anything
I'm sure plenty of you guys have read
the books or seen the other adaptation
that's been made for this like they're
made-for-tv movie or something for those
who are unfamiliar with any of that
material come on make this critter I
haven't seen that made-for-tv movie or
read the book I don't know how like
similar this all plays out but I will
say in the last half is when I really
found
that this movie found its footing and I
think that was the common consensus
around the entire group that we were
talking with or any individual who
interacted with afterwards it was the
last half of the film where the
direction of the movie finds a good
pacing and the movie gets a lot darker
around this point of the movie and it
seemed like that's when Ava Duvernay
really knew what she wanted to do with
the movie it gets creepy in all the
right places there's some real awesome
stylistic choices that's when I found
myself emotionally invested I think that
the last half makes the movie worth it
especially as a movie theater to go and
experience reason not to see a choppy
rushed first half honestly in the first
half I actually had some negative
thoughts that kept going through my mind
of this is one of those situations when
a director who hasn't worked with a
budget this massive before doesn't
really know how to handle it with all
the new toys she has at her disposal
right now in the first half the editing
and direction are especially off in my
opinion you said that you were able to
notice a lot of the script being off I
think we both did but I just feel like
the first half of this movie feels
really truncated and rushed like
someone's like we got a hurry up and I'm
like this this is a less than two hour
movie for my overall enjoyment I could
have used some breathing room and some
of those scenes feeling under written
all that kind of goes to me sort of
being lost in the experience until later
when it finally gives you something to
really latch on to and that later it
comes in the last half and in the first
half the editing to me is especially off
because yes it is fast paced but there
were just choices in terms of how the
scenes were cut together a lot of the
time you'd have like a smooth shot and
then a random insert that was super
handheld and then a different angle than
a different angle than a different angle
and like one scene and like people
talking it just kept throwing me off
some of this kind of reminded me of my
experience when I was watching Quantum
of Solace for the first time you walk
into it and you're like wow I wasn't
expecting so much random handheld camera
work in this movie where it's like are
they going for like a gritty realistic
tone in a fantasy sci-fi movie like a
wrinkle in time because it's just not
meshing well to the point where they
when they finally get to full-on sci-fi
fantasy
I wasn't feeling the wonder that I
the movie wanted me to feel as a matter
of fact I don't think I even had any
emotional investment because while the
performances were great I still wasn't
emotionally invested in the first half
of what was going on it wasn't so that's
that where I was like well I'm awake now
I'm home I'm tuned in
yeah the first half glimmers with little
bits of potential here and there they're
good you know yeah Gorman's notes there
are good visual notes there are good
ideas happening in the first half but
the movie doesn't really reach its
cruising altitude yeah until about the
halfway point and that's about the time
that the movie started to just get
progressively better from there until I
was crying and stuff it's choppy and
it's uneven and it's weirdly directed I
wasn't exactly sure what the style was
in fact sometimes the scenes felt like
they didn't even storyboard I feel it
for a movie like this you have to
storyboard it and there were times where
we really felt like you just got like
random pickups and inserts and then
threw it into the editing room I spent
the first half wondering like why why
are you in such a hurry this is just a
feeling I get more than anything but it
kind of felt like it had just been
really pared down like somebody took the
first half of win no no no we got to
trim all the fat out of this throw in a
couple shots to make these transitions
work better and make some extra
expositional dialogue right it's a
family film but that's part of the
debate that I was having with myself
when I was watching this was that
information in the first half is so
heavy it's outside of the rules we know
as time and space
the aunt arrives in my hand
instantaneous so you follow space more
light so you weren't collect it more
than just being a lot of information and
sometimes it's hard to process
information okay no there's a family
film King kids keep up with this and
then when it gets until last half where
it gets really mature and really dark is
this movie for kids right now because
this is when I feel like the movie is at
its best but it's also way darker than
the first half was the first half is
lighter easier for kids to watch I'm
assuming the information so heavy that
I'm not even sure kids can follow it
then you got the last half which is way
darker more for adults it's gradual I'm
not sure who the audience is for this
film but I will say that the last half
of this movie overall makes it worth
watching yeah I mean it leaves you with
their or left me with a good impression
overall despite you know some solid
complaints I feel like yeah franchise
the dad gets lost again every time every
time the dad gets lost and then the
third one mom gets lost yeah cuz she's
jealous that her husband keeps cheating
on shaking hands with the universe yeah
she wants to feel less insecure so she
wants to shake hands with the universe
now yeah that's what the last half of
this movie is like alright guys well did
you see a wrinkle in time yet maybe not
this reviews coming out a little bit
early but if you did do you prefer that
made-for-tv movie or prefer this did you
read the book do you have a fresh in
your mind
how does it compare to this film do you
like Oprah do you think she should run
for president guys you can subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
well again notified every time one of
our videos is up check us out on patreon
full-length music video and TV show
reactions over there as well as weekly
Q&A s we are covering several shows I
personally am covering attack on Titan
the flash John what are the shows you're
covering personally at the moment
Riverdale and Runaways and Rick and
Morty on occasion and then together we
are covering together black light
lightning my hero academia will probably
be covering Jessica Jones this weekend
next week too so keep a lookout for that
thanks for tuning and reject nation how
do you have